how does
egg donation for assisted reproduction
affect evolutionary biology
how does it relate to concepts like
certainty of maternity
or the comment on the last stream that
all of your ancestors were successful
as there's a parenthetical here ends
with the recipient
point being that egg donation
effectively creates two mothers one of
whom is not
um successful in the usual genetic
standard sense
yeah well i think very frequently we um
we lose track of the essential element
that we are
um that we should be tracking for a
given purpose so for example
when people say oh uh that's not
you know his biological child or
something like that when somebody has
been adopted
my sense is no
a father for example who raises a child
has tremendous influence in a most
biological fashion
you have to understand that culture is
biology every bit as much as genes
so it is fair to say that somebody is
not someone's genetic child
but it is wrong to say that it is not
somebody's biological child
and to say that you know it
happens we don't have any adopted
children but if uh
you know if if we did and that child
said well that's not my
uh that's not my real father right no
your real father is actually much
more the person who raised you than it
is the person who donated the genes for
one thing
the genes uh aren't all that variable in
interesting ways
what you learn from your father is
tremendously variable and so the point
is
we should be tracking the important part
in the case of
donated eggs you know you've got uh
from evolution's perspective it's the
genetic lineage that matters
from the perspective of the human stuff
that's actually important
right it is certainly going to be the
person who raises the offspring
and so um the question is for what
purpose
right there's also i mean it it further
splits up
you know adoption is something that's
been around for
at least thousands of years and probably
millions actually because we see
we see children being adopted
effectively by
um other mothers who are at the
appropriate developmental stage with
their own children in
in chimps and bonobos i believe um but
typically by relatives
typically by relatives yes um
if uh you know if their mother dies
right only only under duress
um but this idea of egg donation does
does partition this even more you know
so you
you do have even more impact on a
child's development
even if it's not your genes that you
know even if you didn't
um contribute either of the gametes to
the child but if you carried that child
in in your womb for nine months that's
that's an a that's
a lot of input that's a lot of
environmental input
that uh that you would not have
otherwise so it's
um you know so it's it's you're
impacting that child's
life um from an even earlier stage than
you do when you adopt a child
at birth yep
it also is the case that in
in an implanted egg i mean for one thing
a woman can
preserve eggs and then have them
fertilized and
and reintroduced later in her life but
this also introduces a kind of
uncertainty of maternity
that's previously this is in the
question it's never been an issue for
females so
the basic answer is look this has every
impact on
the genetic thing which is what
evolution in the narrow sense
cares about it is not at all what we
should care about
and therefore there's a question of can
we track the parameters that matter
most like what sort of
human will be created how uh capable
fulfilled yeah decent will they be but i
mean we still
so much of society is still around
basically issues of certainty fraternity
whether or not people know that sure
right like people don't like to talk
about it and want to pretend it's not
true but
the fact that certainly paternity has
driven uh mating systems and social
systems and
and all civilizations uh forever uh
doesn't change just because we should be
focusing on the other stuff and so
the idea of introducing this new
uncertainty
uh this certainty of maternity um is
is a very interesting question although
i think really except
i mean i just i'm not too familiar with
all the sort of reproductive assisted
technologies and
and the ways that they they they get
used but
often i would think um that really you
just
you just have certainty of non-maternity
really like if you know if you
if you are a woman who can carry a child
and desperately wants a child and
um you just your eggs can't do it um you
simply know that the child that you're
carrying doesn't have your genetics but
it has
everything else you know you know you
still know you've given birth to that
child
and that child is yours from from day
one it just doesn't happen to have your
genes
so so there's you're flipping a switch
but you haven't actually increased
um uncertainty any you just have gone
from
yeah i'm certain i am the genetic mother
to i'm certain i'm not
right unless you're donating eggs to
yourself but
um yeah so like so for this like
i i'm i know my eggs are good now and
i'm hoping for a moment ten years in the
future or something okay right yeah
um but you know what you have is a
mismatch between
the genetic reality about which i'm
arguing you should care very little
and the realities that matter about
which you should care in proportion to
the degree to which
they matter and i think heather's point
here which
i agree with is that it doesn't make the
stuff
that doesn't matter any less important
to the motivational structure that you
have inherited
but that motivational structure will
interface with
the realities that you actually care
about arbitrarily so
in some sense it's the same puzzle as
for people who are young
and fertile sex is fun because of its
reproductive
potential at the point you interfere
with its reproductive potential
with birth control it is no longer
the fun does not correlate with the
increase in reproductive success that is
likely to accompany
that behavior and yet it doesn't become
less fun so
yeah in some sense do you care that you
know that the fun was supposed to be
because you were gamble you were playing
baby roulette or
no i think that's actually maybe the
most relevant thing here because
actually since there is exactly no
history
of uncertainty of maternity in the
mammalian lineage
uh the fact that we've now introduced
uncertainty or certainty of
non-maternity
is so new that it's equivalent to
messing with the psychology with regard
to birth control which is to say it's
not insignificant but it has no
evolutionary history yeah
yeah now i should point out that
uncertainty of maternity is very
different
than just being unsure of your mom
because mom says some crazy stuff and
sometimes you just find yourself unsure
of your mom and
did zack pay you to say that i wasn't
talking about you
i was talking about you mom um all right
now we're in it
[Music]